confused by crypto bamboozled by the
blockchain
nonplussed by non-fungible tokens you're
not alone the economists finance experts
mature fava and alice fullwood talk to
executive editor helen joyce about the
fundamentals of cryptocurrencies and the
technologies that make them possible
depending on who you listen to it can be
described as a haven for scammers the
future of finance a slow-motion
ecological disaster or all three at once
perhaps we could start by defining some
of our terms well crypto originally as
as you said refers to cryptography which
is the
study of secure communications and
that's the set of technologies
allowing for sending a message that only
the sender and the recipients can read
and in the case of cryptocurrencies that
that's money but crypto today is also
uh used to describe the entire universe
of crypto assets
and these are assets as we will discuss
later we'll explain how they work that
do not rely on third parties like
central banks or banks to authenticate
their value or authenticate uh
their movements brilliant i think that
you've got very hard one now and alice
every time someone's tried to explain
the blockchain to me i understand it
while they're speaking and then i forget
it all as soon as they've stopped sure
so a blockchain is just a database uh
but it's a special kind of database so
rather than being stored on sort of a
single computer by a single institution
like a bank
say
it is a database that is distributed
across lots of computers uh called nodes
and they each have a copy of this
database and they update it uh in blocks
so a new block of transactions is added
to the chain that is stored that's where
the blockchain comes from and as matu
was talking about the blockchain is sort
of a key part of crypto it was invented
with the invention of bitcoin and it
helps uh add new transactions without
appealing to a single centralized entity
uh everyone in the uh computer network
has to agree for a new block to be added
all right i understood that much um
mining mature this is you so mining is a
is another tricky one uh which is
related to what alice just explained so
to add new blocks to to the chain uh you
you need to validate a certain number of
transactions and this is done by a a
number of users on the network and what
they do is they pick a number of
transactions that happen in in real time
and they
they decide which one they want to to
validate
uh they validate them they verify you
know who's sending the money is it going
to the right person
is is our enough funds available
at the sender's account
uh or things like that
um and once they've done that because
they all do it at the same time only one
person can actually add a block they
need to compete
in a pretty complex mathematical problem
whose winner will decide who has the
right to add block to the blockchain
and they they don't do this for free
even though presumably it's it's fun to
do um they do it because in exchange if
they win the right to add this block
then they receive some uh some bitcoin
if they're mining bitcoin or some other
currencies if it's another one and
speaking of currencies what about you
alice bitcoin
yes so bitcoin is the first uh crypto
currency or crypto asset that was
invented uh it was first issued in
january of 2009 and its creator satoshi
nakamoto um
he
came up with this sort of idea of a
blockchain and the first blockchain was
designed to record transactions in
bitcoin so
it is the token that the miners receive
for adding blocks to the blockchain and
it is the sort of native asset of that
chain
and you know it was initially worth very
little basically zero um and today is by
far the biggest uh cryptocurrency by
market cap and is sort of the most
famous of all of them and ethereum we're
hearing a lot more about matia
so ethereum is uh is the new kid on the
block i mean it's not so new anymore but
it definitely was when it came out it's
uh it's younger than bitcoin uh it's in
many ways nimbler than it because it
uses or it is it's it's it's yes it's
created
uh transactions um
that are done in ethereum are recorded
on the different type of blockchain
which spare the same name
um and which is just more nimble more
modern uh allows users of that
currency to do many more things many
more complex uh
financial transactions which we'll
discuss when we speak about defy
so it's it's um it's the the challenger
but it's a big challenger
okay and nft you said alice what's an
nft
yes uh nft stands for non-fungible token
um and the non-fundable sort of part of
that term is supposed to distinguish
these kinds of tokens from
the likes of bitcoin and ethereum so
they are fungible uh as is the us dollar
if you swap one bitcoin for another or
one ethereum for another or a dollar for
another
you have the same value uh non-fundable
tokens are
instead attached to unique assets so
that's either a piece of media like a
picture or a video uh or a piece of
music even and it's essentially a
cryptocurrency token that is issued with
reference to that media and it means
that you own some
uh some
i guess almost the idea of that media uh
so if someone who owns an artwork issues
uh an nft in it and they sell that to
you you you might not own the artwork
but you own the nft that represents it
so maybe i could ask you both to tell me
um when you're writing about
cryptocurrencies how do you keep your
your head straight it's so confusing is
there a trick for thinking about it it's
a challenge to write about crypto
because there's also a lot of uh of
jargon that's being used to describe
things that you could probably describe
in in a slightly simpler way you know in
uh for example people who were hold on
to their crypto are called the huddlers
and that
dates back to a time when a pretty
frustrated investor in crypto would sold
it to creep too quickly
and vented his hangar on
on twitter after plus drinking a bit too
much wine and he misspelled he said oh
you guys are the ho the hodlers
you know saying basically i should have
done like you did and he created a
concept that's extremely popular these
days so i guess one
one one way to to keep track is to uh
get uh you know behind the dragon to try
and understand exactly what people mean
but also to have fun with this these new
concepts which you know are quite
colorful anything you'd like to add to
that uh alice so you'll pick up a crypto
story you know once um once every sort
of few months maybe a bit a big one and
i find that if i haven't been been
reading about it that much um i get very
frustrated immediately with all of the
sort of nonsense and terms and
everything that everyone is talking
about and i'm just like oh god this is
all rubbish like why are we even bother
bothering and then once i sort of read
more and more and more and i do all of
my reporting i'm like i become sort of
more on the evangelical side where i'm
like no no this is it this is everything
it is this sort of beautiful dream um
and i just i guess i don't know how
realistic it is but um
it it can it can draw you in if you if
you read about it enough
i'm sasha niata executive editor at the
economist this was part of a digital
event produced exclusively for
subscribers to the economist if you'd
like to watch the full recording of this
or any of our other events please click
the link
you'll have to register first or you can
subscribe to the economist and enjoy all
of our journalism thanks for watching